Twitter is still of course functioning
but based on the title of this episode
Twitter is dead is a figure of speech
engagement is way down and I noticed
this earlier people have been talking
about it for several weeks and people
have been talking about how if you lock
your profile on Twitter
you'll get more engagement
doesn't seem to make sense to me
something's wrong with the machine and
we had this story as Twitter thread from
Dave Rubin last week where he talked
about the fractal Rube Goldberg machine
that was Twitter and that there were
actually secret codes new codes that
were censoring conservatives that were
censoring people like Dave Rubin so the
reason why I say it's dead is because
two things happen engagement disappeared
something happened in the algorithm a
couple weeks ago where all of a sudden
people stopped getting comments replies
they stopped getting retweets stop
getting quote tweets they stopped
getting likes and everybody said yo
what's going on it feels like Twitter is
dying people aren't engaging anymore
maybe everybody States Twitter now I
doubt it something changed in the system